Let's see, let's go next two.
Why don't we go to our caller from the two
oh three area code.
Who's calling today from two oh three.
Hey David, this is me.
Yes, that's you.
Yeah.
Hi.
Um, so I'm curious about your take about the
supreme court.
Um, I know recently brain serious came out
and said that they, he's against, um, increasing
the number of judges in Supreme Court and,
but he's pro, um, I guess circuit of like
judges come through.
Uh, what was your take on that?
Yeah, I, I, uh, I've seen some convincing
arguments about stacking the court, packing
the court and increasing the number of justices.
I do also think that it's one of those things
where if if we do it then it's opening up
the door for them to do it and the, the reality
is that right now the left has much more to
lose from not changing the, the structure
of the Supreme Court because Donald Trump
partially thanks to Mitch McConnell's obstruction
of Merrick garland has already had two supreme
court picks and there is potentially going
to be a very conservative supreme court for
a long time.
So I understand the appeal although I worry
about opening up that door.
Um, in terms of the idea of supreme court
justices not serving for life, I, I find that
very interesting as well.
The only problem is like with all of these
things, once you know you are not going to
be serving for life, you potentially could
be influenced in terms of how you decide cases
based on whether maybe there is a party to
one of those cases that after you are no longer
on the court you might consult for or work
for or whatever.
And it creates a lot of complicated issues
related to conflicts of interest and recusal.
So I like a lot of these ideas and I also
recognize some of the shortfalls of them.
Okay.
Yeah, I've, uh, seen, uh, some, some proposal
builds of like, uh, I mean, uh, judges and,
uh, both a congressman and the Senate, uh,
to, you know, like not get into the industry
is after they leave office.
Um,
well that's the thing, if you limit with,
with Supreme Court justices, if you say you
no longer have a lifetime appointment, but
you also have to agree not to work for any
of the industries whose cases you hear while
you're on the court, it becomes almost impossible,
right?
Like what are they expected to do?
Because Supreme Court hears so many different
cases.
So I don't know what the solution is, but
I think that we, there's definitely improvements
to be made.
All right.
Thank you David.
Okay.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you very much.